"Castle" followed a tried-and-true TV formula.
Nathan Fillion starred as crime novelist Richard
Castle and Stana Katic played homicide detective
Kate Beckett.
The two mismatched characters improbably paired
up to solve crimes in New York City.
Though Kate initially resented Castle being
around, the romantic tension between the two
couldn't be ignored, and they struck up a
romantic relationship.
Behind the scenes, sparks also flew, but in
a bad way.
In 2015, tensions supposedly came to a head,
and Katic suddenly exited the show after eight
seasons as one of the leads.
There were rumors that Fillion demanded she
be written off the show, though his only public
statement about the situation was a 2016 Twitter
post in which he thanked Katic and wished
her well.
In a 2018 interview with Entertainment Weekly,
Katic finally opened up about her firing, saying,
"I'm actually still not clear on the thought
process behind the way that it went down.
It hurt, and it was a harsh ending."
ABC canceled "Castle" in 2016, before a Katic-less
ninth season could be made.